I'm talking with Kay Heimat she's the
William e Simon fellow at the Manhattan
Institute she has a great article in
city journal called the plight of the
alpha female so Kay this was fascinating
now you point out that American women
are better educated than their male
counterparts they're quickly becoming
the breadwinners in the household they
one more Olympic medals as last year's
Summer Olympics but at the very top
fortune 500 companies investment firms
and law firms not a lot of women at the
very top why is that well one word the
children mothers are more likely to take
time off than fathers they're or to take
longer periods of time off they are more
likely to work part time they are more
likely to cut back hours in all kinds of
ways if you look at the if you compare
the number of hours work by men and
women you'll find quite a difference
it's one of the reasons for the
well-known gender wage gap so what
happens is that as women are climbing up
the career ladder they're doing great
until their mid-30s or so or earlier mid
30s and then they tend to back off and
that's of course when the children come
so my view is that we're never going to
see the kind of precise exact equality
that we that we might have hoped at the
very top now you agree that it is
childbearing that causes this the shift
and a Marie slaughter wrote a cover
piece for The Atlantic called women why
women still can't have it all that's and
she she pines for that equality do you
think that's necessary do you agree that
there is injustice well I mean it's an
injustice I suppose if you have a clear
sense that it's got to be absolute
parity and I guess I don't I don't
believe that that has to be I think that
in fact we're doing young women and men
a disservice by having them expect that
there are one of the reasons that
anne-marie slaughter wrote that article
and one of the reasons she got such an
enormous response to it is that young
women went thank you for talking about
this
dilemma because my generation of mothers
were so determined to see their
daughters read you reach this absolute
parity and a lot of young women are
finding it's not possible or that
they're not happy this is not to say
there's no discrimination anywhere there
there is but my reading of the situation
is that it's largely driven by a lack of
female possibilities as it comes as they
come through the pipeline they more and
more drop out whether it's a business
whether it's in the legal world and
whether it's in in the higher levels of
government you're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't
well look there's a tension between
being an engaged parent and being an
alpha I mean if you know this is this is
is that an injustice I think that's just
life you know and and we can't it's a
tension that I don't see how can it can
ever be fully resolved there are things
we can do to make it easier for not just
women but men have a more active family
life there we you know we we should be
talking and are talking a lot about flex
time but there's always going to be
somebody else who is working through all
those years and producing through all
those years and achieving through all
those years where you and you know and
your husband or wife is taking time off
and there's nothing we can do about that
in terms of creating as I say absolute
parity there is a counterintuitive
aspect of this where at some law firms
where they don't have the most
family-friendly flextime practices women
do achieve higher status why is that
well because there is no mommy track so
the women who go into those firms are
the ones who are completely career
oriented a lot of them don't have
children by the way I mean if you look
at the statistics the women who are at
the top are more likely than not always
but more likely to be childless than the
men at the top so that tells
right there there's a different kind of
approach to to like it by the way
another piece of evidence for all of
this is in Europe so I looked at the
data on in Sweden and in France these
are very so-called family-friendly
countries where there are all kinds of
benefits for young parents which is fine
you know I didn't go in but trade paid
maternity pay maternity leave and in
Sweden paternity leave is almost
required I mean it's a little
complicated how they said I don't need
to go into that now but my real point is
this in the public sector women are have
achieved some kind of parity in the
private sector they have not and in fact
if anything if you look at the numbers
at the very top American women are doing
better than Swedish women so the
question is why and what economists have
been speculating about as they've
studied this is that the maternity leave
actually puts women on this mommy track
which makes it harder to achieve an
extremely competitive environment
Melissa Mayer who is the CEO at Yahoo I
mean she promised that she was going to
take maternity leave it was only going
to be a couple weeks so it wasn't the
normal expansion was going to work she's
going to work through it I mean it is
that compromising childbearing is that
does that send a bad message to women I
think it's not sending a bad message to
women to say that some women are really
going to want to keep the their foot on
the gas pedal as Sheryl Sandberg has put
it but I think it's a mistake for women
to come away from that and say yes yes
this is possible for everybody and and
and desirable for everybody it just
isn't
Sheryl Sandberg who's the CFO at
Facebook she leaves work every day at
5:30 to have dinner with her family has
technology helped having
videoconferencing and constant access to
email and everything else does that
create parity in itself
oh absolutely that dad has changed
everything
I mean you we wouldn't even be having
this
conversation 3040 years ago not just
because women didn't have the same
expectations for rising but because it
wasn't possible to keep your hands on
the kids at the same time that you were
climbing the career ladder in a way that
you can do it now now the American left
has become very preoccupied with income
inequality here in the United States and
has your insight into female CEOs in
this country shed any light on that
subject yeah I think that there I'm not
looking at the data very carefully I
mean there's a tendency to mash together
all of the numbers in a way that what
makes it look like there's this terrible
discrimination going on but in my own
research what I've found is that
actually women are working fewer hours
than men when we say women are only
making 77 cents on the dollar let's say
which is which is the current number
that's most often cited that doesn't
take into account that they are working
fewer hours that they're working in
different in different occupations so
I'll just give you an example and them
in the medical world among doctors women
are far less likely to be surgeons than
they are to be pediatricians well
surgeons make more than pediatricians is
that because they're men no it's because
the skill involved that life-and-death
decisions the hours all of that is
recompense in a different way so what is
the ultimate fix and where do you come
down on the Mommy Wars is it a false
battle is there no one-size-fits-all fix
for the problem absolutely there's no
one sighs you know there's an enormous
variation in how women and men are going
to see this and I think the idea that
you often hear from from the Left Front
feminists from triggered more
traditional feminists is you know that
we're going to have these 50/50
arrangements some people are most people
are not they're going to find other ways
of of trying to deal with these tensions
that I've been talking about because
there's such an assumption of
discrimination there is then the
conclusion that we need all sorts of
government programs
laws legislations and probe and various
kinds of petitions or whatever to to
fight this supposed discrimination my
reading of it is that discrimination
plays a role but not a very large one
thank you very much okay you can click
on her article right here for city
journal the plight of the alpha female
for reason TV I'm Kennedy